I read with interest as everyone had
their different arguments some people
added some different sort of language on
it like the word your number density
nobody's together really close so that
was a very clever way to do it okay
here's how I think most people argued
I'm going to put us on a number line
okay okay so if you've got if you've got
some integers like this okay you're like
look I can go ahead and I can count all
of these up right but then you would say
to me ah hold on hold on if I'm trying
to do this whole pairing business right
if I'm trying to approach it that way
look you match one metronome up with
some rational but hold on hold on these
are all rational nuns themselves right
so you're like this guy is matched up
with a rational number namely itself
this guy's next matched up with the
rational number namely himself and you
keep going right and then you've got all
of these leftovers right so you got all
these guys okay right and I can keep on
doing this forever and if you want to
follow that kind of argument you can say
well hold on a second if there's an
infinite number of integers or natural
numbers okay but we can also say surely
between zero and one there's an infinite
number of fractions right so therefore
you could kind of argue this size is
infinity and then this one would be like
infinity times infinity because for
every one of these every pair of numbers
you've got to infinity in between there
my brain hurts already
okay well guess what
if we think about this diagonally I can
show you actually it's not the case
there probably is how he sent up this is
how I laid out the the natural
but we can lay them out another way in
fact let's draw all of the rational
numbers listing out the bachelor so he's
mine now you're like well this will take
this will take a lot of time right but
it depends on how you do it okay for
instance if I write this okay this is a
nice logical way of laying out the
natural numbers so you can see I haven't
missed any right and if I just keep me
going and I fall in the pattern I'll get
them all I'll catch them all it's all
right question yeah
well strictly speaking I need these as
well yeah he goes in both directions but
you'll see it won't matter if I go
towards or not now here's my question to
you and I'll give you a second to think
about it on your own or in a pair if
this is how you lay out then at the
integers and don't miss any how would
you lay out the rational numbers in such
a way that you make sure you don't miss
any now I'm gonna let you try it okay
I'll give you a clue this way forever
it's not gonna cut it because clearly
I'm missing a lot of fractions right
in fact I'm missing an infinite number
of fractions to here here and here yeah
this is not gonna work okay so can you
lay out the rational numbers in some
other way so I know when I look at your
list and I see then another not bother
God that you've got all of them I'll
give you a couple minutes to think about
how you might do this the point is
if I can lay these all out it's some
kind of logical sequence then I can
start to do this I can start to match
things and then I can see if this will
work out so here's the way I'm gonna do
it okay and he's the way you can write
all of the rational numbers it's really
not that hard okay we're gonna start
with is where we began with the number
line okay so for instance if I have 101
I'm not gonna worry about zero because
you'll see this argument will continue
to apply if I have zero if I have any
numbers it'll work out I'm gonna write
out all the numbers with denominator one
okay I'm gonna have one on one to
everyone three over one no big deal
and this will go on forever okay so far
so good
but you're like uh missing a lot of
numbers that's true I don't have any
with denominator 2 for instance but
that's okay I can write those in I'll
have 1 over 2 all that - River - don't
worry I've already got here but that's
okay I'll have 3 over 2 4
I can hold on hold on don't go yet
nothing yet
now just leave a slide for a second
the fact that I've got repeats here okay
you can see this is a repeat with this
and this is RP with this but guess what
it's gonna work any right now I'm still
missing fractions right what fractions
am I missing - nominated three
denominator well you know what I'm just
gonna say doc doc doc right I'm doing
the same thing this way as I am this way
can you see horizontally I'm changing
the numerators vertically I'm changing
the denominator right so you're used to
in corner geometry they say this is the
x-axis and this is the y-axis and you're
used to people tell you just have these
axes because because I said so okay well
guess what
you can define whatever axes you like
whatever is useful to you this this is
the numerator axes like changing the
numerators and this is the denominator
axis okay
now what I'm trying to do I trending
this thing I'm trying to pair up now you
will see if I start over here and say go
this way
I'm stuck right I have my big pile of
integers natural numbers and negative
okay and I start walking this way and I
walk forever and I never get to the end
and this is your argument before you
said look you missed all of these notes
so I think okay well now therefore go
down this way what if I go down this way
and I keep walking down I'm still gonna
run out of numbers right I'm gonna go
all the way down here and I will never
have touched any of these unless unless
I go diagonally so here's what I'm going
to do I'm gonna start here because that
looks like a good place to start okay
and then they say they're going that way
or that way I'm gonna go well let's come
around this way like so and then I'll go
here and then here give a diagonal so
now I've covered all these and now I'm
gonna come back around like this
like so okay and here's the thing right
you're like we'll you'll never get to
the end but that's okay I have a bag
that is bottomless I'll always be able
to pull out more more integers right and
I'm never gonna miss one that was the
problem you gave me before right
if I go down this way you're like oh
you've missed all these and never touch
them or if I go across this way on this
all these and never touch these right
but if I go in a diagonal there's never
gonna be one this down I'm gonna get to
every single one I'm gonna pair up every
one of these with one of these every
rational number is gonna get covered
does that make sense
so he's he is the result that comes out
of this okay if you've got the integers
but and you say what's the size of the
integers right well like like that crazy
massive primary school kids oh I don't
know how many there are
but I can match them all up with the
rational numbers so that means the size
of those sets the sizes of those sets
they both the same yes that's right let
me take that idea a little further
okay let's consider let's consider and I
wonder if you can anticipate the
argument before I give it to you okay
let's consider the set of well let's
call this one just the natural numbers
and then let's consider all of the even
numbers now which do you think there
would be more off right now if you think
from a density point of view right
you're like well clearly there are more
natural numbers right because the even
numbers are spaced out right oh but
guess what I can match these guys up
easily I can match them up what's this
here are all of the here all the natural
numbers
and here are all the even numbers I can
match them up like this look one I'll
match with its double to old man
Chapman's double three am I ever going
to miss any I'm not this one's gonna go
forever this one's gonna go forever and
I haven't missed there are no gaps I've
caught them more right and there's way
more than actually I was gonna say 251
but that's not there's not that many
Pokemon anyways so I can catch them all
there are none missed just like with the
diagonal right
I'm margins aren't sure take me forever
but that's okay I've got an infinite
number of these to put matching to
matching right you're all going to match
off